Hey, this is sort of funny.
Um, Joe Biden is hilariously claiming to be
the most progressive candidate running in
the 2020 Democratic primary, which is obviously
not true.
Now, Biden actually said this a couple of
weeks ago before he even announced he was
running.
And in the clip I'm going to play for you.
You'll notice that Biden sort of slips and
says he's the most progressive candidate running,
even though at the time he wasn't running.
And it was sort of a signal that pretty clearly
he's going to be.
But the point of all this is Joe Biden claiming
to be the most progressive candidate.
Take a look at this.
No, I get criticized.
He told on your true size by the new left
eye, the most progressive record of anybody
running for the u, not anybody who would run
it.
[inaudible]
so this is simply not true like that.
There are many things that we can say about
Biden that are true and I told you some of
them and they're not all things I'm thrilled
with and they're not.
All things are audiences thrilled, thrilled
with it.
So Joe Biden's polling really well.
Okay.
There are a number of new polls that came
out over the weekend.
Um, one from Harvard.
Harris has Biden polling it, 44%.
Okay.
Even if off by several points, that's huge.
The latest CNN poll has Biden polling 39%.
The latest Quinnipiac poll has Biden polling
38%.
I know that there are people who will take
issue with individual polls, but these are
good numbers and you can take issue with liking
Biden.
You can say Biden is not a progressive, which
I say, but it's a true statement that Biden
is polling really well.
You can accurately say Biden's raising a ton
of money.
Okay?
He set a record for the first 24 hours among
other 2020 candidates.
Did Joe Biden's money come from larger donations
from a smaller pool of donors?
Absolutely.
As I told you about last week, but it's true
that Joe Biden raise more money in his first
day than any other of the 2020 Democratic
candidates, but there's no factual case to
be made that Joe Biden's in the most progressive
candidate here is Bernie Sanders when asked
about this over the weekend saying, uh, yeah,
that's not the case.
Well, I'm sure you saw Joe Biden say that
he is the most progressive candidate in this
race.
Well, look good.
Joe is a good friend of mine and I'm not here
to attack Joe.
Oh, Joe voted for the war in Iraq.
I led the effort against the Joe voted for
Nafta and permanent normal trade relations,
trade agreements with Trane.
I helped lead the effort against that.
Uh, Joe Rock voted for the deregulation of
Wall Street.
I voted against that.
Uh, you know, I think if you look at Joe's
record and you look at my record, I don't
think there's much question about who's more
progressive.
Joe Biden is not the most progressive candidate
obviously, and that should be made crystal
clear.
What's problematic is that there are some
on the left saying Biden is just like Trump
and you've got to just stop being stupid.
Okay.
That's exactly the type of attack that hurts
us in the general election.
Biden's not Trump.
Okay.
Biden's basically Hillary, and as we know
right now, Hillary was not drum.
The Supreme Court would look very different
if Hillary Clinton was president.
Uh, our relationships with many of our historical
allies would look very different if Hillary
Clinton was president.
So there are means floating around.
There's one that has, you know, 20 different
parameters.
And the case it makes is that unlike all,
but one of them, Trump and Biden are the same.
The difference between them being Biden's
polite, whereas Donald Trump is crass.
That's destructive as much as it is silly
and stupid.
Okay.
There's one positive thing here.
I do want to point out in a way sort of good
that Joe Biden feels the need to lie about
being the most progressive.
What I mean in other words is Biden is claiming
to be most progressive because he must believe
that it's good for him to people, for people
to see him as more progressive than he actually
is.
He has assessed that saying, I'm a sensible
center left Democrat.
That doesn't seem as appealing in his mind
to the electorate as claiming to be the most
progressive candidate.
So in a sense that maybe is an indicator that
things are continuing to move to the left.
Uh, in terms of the candidates on the democratic
side, it's simply not true that Biden is the
most progressive Biden's a centrist.
He is, I think what I would call sort of status
quo democrat.
It's not just about where exactly on the political
spectrum is Biden, he's sent her left.
He's, he's basically Hillary.
Um, it's that he is not a progressive candidate,
but if he's the nominee, I'm going to vote
for him over Trump.
I mean this is where I don't want to see the
left evolve into this.
Biden is just like Trump stuff because it's
ridiculous and there are low information voters
who will fall for it.
Biden is endlessly better than Trump, but
he's not what I would describe as a progressive
Democrat and I don't think there's any factual
case you can make to support that claim.
My hope is if Biden ends up being the nominee
and Biden ends up becoming president of the
United States, if Democrats are able to maintain
control of the house in 2020 and 2022 and
then are able to take control of the Senate
in 2022 very unlikely that Democrats would
take control in 2020 of the Senate.
No matter what happens in the White House.
If in 2022 Biden gets the house and the Senate,
I hope that we will have a progressive enough
house and Senate that they will do really
progressive things and Biden will not get
in the way of those things.
It's sort of setting the bar relatively low.
But I think practically speaking, that's kind
of the best case scenario.
If
Joe Biden ends up being president